nous avons passé deux jours avec des
brigades de marine sur ce front qui est
effectivement l'axe de progression à la
fois vers la grande ville de Mario Paul
mais également vers celles de berdience
qu'en fait l'axe de progression vers la
mer d'Azov et là on se rend très bien
compte de la difficulté pour les forces
ukrainiennes sur ce front là ce sont des
milliers et des milliers d'hectares de
champs qui sont tous minés il n'y a pas
de relief pas de hauteur un officier
nous disait d'ailleurs que l'ordre
lorsque l'ordre était donné et bien
d'attaquer la difficulté la principale
difficulté c'était de passer ces champs
de mines car et bien après ensuite se
battre dans les villages étaient pour
lui en tout cas à ses yeux beaucoup plus
simple parce que tout simplement et bien
les villages sont moins miner que ces
hectares de champ nous avons également
pu parler avec des médecins avec des
ambulanciers qui travaillent dans les
points de stabilisation c'est à dire que
ce sont les endroits où sont évacués
d'abord les soldats qui sont blessés sur
le front certains de ces points de
stabilisation reçues jusqu'à 1000
blessés graves depuis le début de la
contre-offensive et ce sont
principalement c'est ce que nous disait
ces médecins et bien à des blessures
causées par des mines que par des mines
antipersonnelles viennent ensuite les
éclats d'obus car on s'en rend compte
aussi les Russes sur ce front pylône les
positions
ukrainiennes à l'artillerie toute la
journée voilà ce que nous disait un
médecin en un mois je n'ai soigné qu'une
seule blessure par balle voilà pour la
situation dans le sud-est donc pendant
ce temps là Gwendoline dans le nord-est
de l'Ukraine cette fois les Russes sont
le Francis
oui effectivement les forces russes
tentent dans le nord-est de percer les
défenses ukrainiennes alors pour
l'instant les positions ukrainiennes
parfois il y a des reculs qui sont
obligatoires mais globalement se feront
la tire mais c'est extrêmement difficile
un certain soldats au sein des
bataillants qui se battent là-bas que
nous avons pu joindre par nous disent
qu'ils ont effectivement beaucoup de
pertes que il est extrêmement difficile
de tenir leur ligne et que les Russes et
bien font une poussée massive à cet
endroit là passer à l'offensive pour les
Russes sur ce front du nord-est qui
n'est pas l'axe majeur de la
contre-offensive ukrainienne et bien
pour les Russes c'est une manière
d'obliger les forces ukrainiennes
l'état-major ukrainien à mettre ses
réserves dans cet endroit qui n'est pas
l'endroit le plus intéressant pour lui
en tout cas pas l'endroit où les forces
ukrainiennes veulent progresser
c'est-à-dire les accès les accès à la
mer